[Music]
thank you
a beautiful Sunday morning to you all
thank you so much for joining us eight
news now covered to the Vegas strong 5K
as so many folks continue their healing
process now as we mark five years since
one October I'm Heather Mills I'm Nathan
tanendum and you know Heather for a lot
of folks a part of the healing process
has been running and so here we are with
the fifth annual Vegas strong 5K and
just a quick programming note Heather I
know we got a lot of Raiders fans that
are tuning in for the Raiders now
program don't worry it will Air it is
just going to be on at 8 30 this morning
so this half hour show will be over at 8
30 then the Raiders now now uh Sherry
swensk is the host in the MC she just
headed over to the start line but first
you know who else we have this morning
Heather we have our very own tasty
Fernandez and he's out there somewhere
where are you JC what's happening
hey Nate hey Heather I am at the start
line everyone's lined up here at the
race itself is about to start in five
minutes and over the years I covered a
lot of 5Ks and there's I'll tell you
what there's a different energy about it
this morning there's a connective energy
I mean everyone has a connection to one
October and I have someone I want to
talk to here this morning her name is
Candace and Candace is in from
California and you're running for
someone's very special who are you
running for today yes I'm running for my
cousin Christiana Duarte and she was one
of the 58 victims that day tell us a
little bit more about your about your
cousin and why you're running today my
cousin was amazing she was 22 years old
and full of life laughter she loved
country music she loved to sing dance
and and she was just an amazing person
her smile was contagious and this is uh
very special too because you have your
family back in California and they're
doing the Run virtually exactly exactly
time we are virtually at her favorite
spot Redondo Beach California so
we're all connected we're together well
Candace thank you so much for joining us
today any of your family here you're
gonna run it means the world to us that
you're out here today and just you know
Las Vegas loves you and you always have
our support thank you so much thank you
Candace I appreciate it guys there's so
many people out here running Nicole you
come over here as well and had we look
the race is about the starting we're
spinning around here the races just
started so there goes the runners this
is the 5K it is it is a special morning
it starts with the 5K the runners
through the run-up to Las Vegas
Boulevard make a left a total of three
miles and they are off so I also have
Nicole with me here and Nicole you have
a lot of friends that were out there on
one October so what does it mean to you
to be out here today yeah it really
means a lot for me to be here I know a
lot of people in our community were
really negatively impacted by this event
and this tragedy
um and so I'm part of Farmers Insurance
and I think it's a good opportunity for
us to give back to many of our customers
and employees that were also negatively
impacted and you have a group of friends
out here so you're doing the run so good
luck to you today and then real fast too
look at that I got this guy over here
you talk about dedication come on over
here what is your name how you doing
Giovanni Hernandez and you are running
in your gear today yes sir so why did
you come out here for this race today uh
most importantly just Community Support
I mean obviously the unfortunate event
that happened October 1st there's any
light that came out of it was just the
community support and the love and so so
I'm here running in my gear making sure
that I'm acclimated for any Hazard that
may arise around here that's dedication
this is Vegas strong right here the
runners are running you go running and
you're uh your your gear there and thank
you so much I want to send it back to
you Nate and Heather
boy I think that's really incredible JC
you know to hear the the phrase the
Vegas strong it goes such beyond our
community you had Candace who's talking
about her family and friends in
California and we know how much this
impacts people all across the country
and they're here today I mean more than
2 000 people out here reading which is
amazing including uh most folks from Las
Vegas but we have folks from many other
states I understand we have some Runners
from Canada who are with us today it is
an incredible event it just kicked off
now we know that Sherry was been very
busy uh welcoming folks and being the MC
ever since the very first Vegas strong
5K Sherry this race has grown how are
you doing over there
we're doing great we're right in the
middle of the crowd check this out
everybody they are ready ready for a
wonderful wonderful morning everybody is
Vegas strong thank you guys for being
here where are you from where are you
from
Suffolk Virginia Virginia
where are you from Henderson
biggest Streeter Illinois uh Illinois
Illinois where are you from Atlanta
Georgia Atlanta Georgia oh my God
Illinois Houston Texas oh my goodness
from everywhere in Henderson
it is amazing and the street is still
full you guys they're still going past
you they're still going through the
start line oh the spirits are high
Everybody's Got Love friendship this is
definitely the road to Healing you
betcha good morning hi you guys it is so
great to see you thank you for being
here Battle Born you know it good
morning so all the the funds raised from
the Vegas strong 5K five years running
now it goes to victims funds it goes to
the children of the victim's family and
it goes for Education Cynthia Gainey is
the founder of just run and she's the
founder and director of this event she
has raised so much money let's take a
look at those scholarships where the
money goes
just seven weeks after the one October
shooting the first Vegas strong 5K hit
the pavement raising money for those
still reeling with pain and loss and now
five years strong the event has become
an annual reunion people want to be here
they want to come together and Remember
Las Vegas local and organizer Cynthia
Gainey uses her running event company
just run to bring thousands together
each October to run and walk the road to
Healing this year registrations are from
across the country and Canada and as far
away as Europe people kept saying we
want this to continue every year every
year and I said I will continue to put
it on as long as people want it 100 of
the proceeds go to victims funds and
scholarship programs for Las Vegas
students like Maggie Louie now a junior
at UNLV I think it's just part of your
own
passion to like save people Louie is
studying to become a doctor she says her
scholarship alleviates a lot of the
financial burden for her to become a
first responder so she can be part of a
positive change you see that more people
are caring about each other in a way
that's like how are you doing like are
you okay and I think the community is
more united in that way we see these
Scholarships in combination with all the
other services that are happening across
our community as one of the ways that we
can come together and heal and remember
what happened on one October Kirsten
Seer is president of the public
Education Foundation which Awards
various scholarships funded since the
2017 tragedy she says events like the
Vegas strong 5K help Empower our young
people to build a stronger community and
never forget and certainly we're seeing
that in the essays from our students
they're still feeling this and it hasn't
gone away and it probably shouldn't have
gone away we need to we need to remember
it we need to continue to talk about it
and recover together I will naturally
become a part of Vegas strong
and I hope to be able to spread that
message to other people as well we just
continue to do this and everybody's
going to come together and whether you
know somebody or not just come out
um participate and you will feel it
you'll feel the support you'll feel the
love Sherry swensk 8 News Now
a really just truly magical event that
goes to so many wonderful things and the
energy as you just saw with Sherry it's
vibrant it's alive people are excited to
be here and happy to be here and to
share that love with our community so
we've got much more coming up as the
runners and Walkers continue to make
their way around the race course yes and
it's really you never know how someone
else's story may work its way into yours
as part of the healing process this is 8
news now live coverage of the Vegas
strong 5K
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the 8 news now coverage
of the Vegas strong 5K and you know Nate
when we talk about Las Vegas we talk
about the glittering lights and the City
Lights the true lights are the people
the true lights are the ones our
community who lives here who've come out
today to be a part of this incredible
event and and the healing process for so
many we've talked about this being the
fifth anniversary of the one October
tragedy and it's in a lot of ways it
seems like was just yesterday in a lot
of ways it's like I cannot believe it's
been five years and here we are a lot of
folks coming up to say hello we're
getting selfies and we're having a good
time talking to people but most of the
runners are on a course right now and I
believe Heather we're going to find out
a little bit more with Sherry who's
still in the middle of it over there hey
Sherry
hi you guys well with me right now is
Cynthia Gainey she is the founder and
director of the Vegas strong 5K and uh
the founder of just run your running
event company
um tell us we just kind of at the tail
end of everybody going through why is
this so near and dear to your heart you
started this through your heart talked
to you five years ago it was important
for you to do this and what have you
seen in the last five years
well the importance of us I grew up in
Las Vegas and uh is my home nothing ever
like this had happened before and you
know a lot of my relatives and everybody
says oh Las Vegas is just you know
gambling and shows and things like that
and when everybody came together after
this happened I mean it proved that we
are a community we're not just the strip
and so because we have this race
management company we wanted to do
something more than just give money but
because we had it I said well let's put
on a race we can raise funds for the
victims fund and we Our intention was
just to have it the first year but after
everybody came together and coming
together with support and love and
healing and they just said please have
it every year so we about to continue to
have it every year so I just saw
Rosemarie Melanson walk past she was one
of the she was injured and she went
through so many surgeries and her road
to Healing was long but her family is
here every year now tell me a little a
bit about what that means to you and to
keep putting on this event for people
like Rosemary and her family well it
just shows that with this kind of an
event it it gives you strength to like I
said move forward One Foot In Front of
the other to get to that ultimate goal
whatever that is for you whatever Finish
Line it is and those her daughters they
were the ones here first and then the
rest of the family started coming and
then when Rosemarie was able to then
they were all here with Grandma and um
it's just every year they get more and
more strong and it's just it's a really
it's an inspiration it's amazing what
you've done and what you did in seven
weeks that first year and what you've
done in five years so thank you so much
and raising over a quarter of a million
dollars for all these victims funds and
scholarships thank you Cynthia Gainey
we're gonna go out on the course now
we're going to see some of the people
walking and running JC Fernandez is out
there show us what's going on JC
lady hey Sherry thank you we're actually
at the Finish Line we're waiting for
some people to cross the finish line for
the first time the race started about 10
minutes ago so we should get some people
coming across is this our first is this
the first one to finish hold on one
second did you just finish the race hey
buddy did you just finish the race
okay what's your name Declan Declan you
know how fast you ran buddy no you were
very fast so why are you out here
running today because because of October
1st that's right well congratulations
what a great job good job buddy there
are some fast Runners out here and here
comes some more Runners and there's
celebrities out here someone told me
that Miranda Lambert is out here and
then of this course our fellow Las Vegas
and what is your name Natalie Carson and
Natalie who are you guys out here for
today we're out for Rosemary Melanson
and she was a friend of yours yes friend
of ours and um she was one of the
victims
um and she was shopping thankfully she
recovered and she's here walking with us
today and we're here with a Cinderella
scholarship program and supporting her
and what does this day mean to you why
are you out here today well the people
who I care about that I'm here today
they are my dance teachers and they were
in this so that's specially Miss
Rosemary because she survived it's
amazing thank you guys for being here
showing the support I know you want to
go join your friends so you can you can
start walking thank you so much for
being here good luck start walking you
guys and more the more people cross the
finish line that is a fast pace here
comes some more people running right now
and I love it it's families running
together
here comes a father and son and look
I'll get this guy real fast when he
finishes over here
[Music]
Let's uh
come over here congratulations you just
finished the race how does it feel
exhilarating exhilarating so what's your
name Ben Ben why are you out here today
buddy
um mostly because my dad dragged me out
here but he's honest he's honest but how
does it feel to finish the race and
knowing you're running for a great cause
feels good yeah yeah I feel proud you're
fast you know that yeah you're real fast
buddy all right now you finished the
race go grab some water there's your
buddy two of the fastest kids in Las
Vegas here congratulations good job guys
all right uh we're waiting for more
Runners to come across we also have the
the fun walk that's taking place the one
mile fun walk so everyone's gonna come
eventually cross this Finish Line but
for now I'm gonna send it back to Nate
and Heather I'll send back to you guys
boy JC that is truly remarkable that's
like a five minute mile man I thought I
saw a smoke bomb behind me which is
incredible breathing hard and we also
have great groups of Runners we heard
the Marines yes they were gearing up and
they were they were shouting out there's
a lot of chance uh we've seen a lot of
dogs a lot of dogs and tutus just people
out here having fun and it's that
camaraderie and the reason that we love
this city so much because we truly are
Vegas strong and there's even some eight
news now folks here too we'll talk about
that they're Milling about
but we do need to take a break and the
eight news now live coverage of the
Vegas strong fifth annual 5K we'll be
right back
foreign
[Music]
news now coverage of the Vegas strong 5K
and Nate we're watching people already
cross the finish line we just saw the
first finisher in the 5K JC was talking
to folks who I think had done the one
mile aha still running fast but yeah he
was flying talk about smoke yeah so uh
we had over 2 000 entrance I think she
said 2100 plus yes yes and uh they're
from all over the country and other
parts of the world as well as we
remember the this fifth year since the
tragedy of one October Lots going on
there's dancers there's uh vendors
there's all kinds of stuff it really is
a fun day and it's family friendly and
the one thing I do want to point out
though of course because as much fun as
we're having we are marking a very
somber occasion and what you'll notice
is the runners do have in memory of yes
every single one yeah so you see those
names and you remember Virgo's stories
that have really just kind of burned
into our Consciousness here five years
later as as we honor their families yeah
and uh we're coming after we had a
one-hour special last night with Brian
and Denise town at the healing Garden
but we want to talk more about what's
happening right here right now is the
fifth annual Vegas strong 5K Sherry's
been talking to some folks what's going
on Sherry
well we're at the finish line now
Heather and Nate and you can see the
first Runners are coming in this is what
the green bite they get bananas they get
fruit they get water but wow I mean some
of these Runners are so fast uh some of
them are First Responders others are
members of our community they've been
here living here and they know exactly
what this was like for them five years
ago so it means a lot to them they've
got family members and friends that
they're running for but mainly they're
just here to support each other
and be here for each other so uh JC's up
he's been talking to a couple of folks
who just finished but here's all the
support of the folks and check this out
I mean they're even running in uh
Wheelchairs and such so it's a very
wonderful morning JC who are you talking
to over there hey Sherry I have the
gentleman who just he finished first the
first one to finish the 5K
congratulations you did it in 16 minutes
and 45 seconds how do you feel feel
great it's very honored to represent the
city of Las Vegas
um I'm happy to be here and win the race
and you did it too because you work at
the Four Seasons so that you're
obviously right across from the tragedy
that night what was that night like for
you
it was a heartbreaking moment I heard
that news when I wake up in the morning
uh ready to go to work
I cannot believe that happening right in
front of my working place so
[Music]
be out here today and do what you did
congratulations my friend you finished
go get some water I think you're
supposed to eat carbs or something like
that carb blood I have one more person I
believe this guy was second
congratulations and who are you running
for I'm running for Jennifer parks in in
memory yes and how fast do you how fast
did you finish the Finish Line I
finished uh
18 16 18 16 and why were you out here
today running why was it so special to
do you're obviously a runner why was it
extra special I'll be out here today for
this race we're here to support uh in
memory of all these people lost their
lives on October 2nd and uh we're here
so do not care about these people thank
you so much for uh for support Channel 8
is a race of course and so they can keep
uh super rather races like this one I
think thank you so much now go drink
some water some Gatorade and place we'll
see carbs when you finish a race like
that how fast are these guys all right
I'm gonna send it back to Nate and
Heather back over to you guys
[Music]
all right JC really just incredible oh
my gosh so the guy who was first he just
pranced right around us like he's still
running yeah but he had a huge smile on
his face cool down oh my God pull down
mode all right uh Clark County of course
we had mentioned yesterday you know such
an important day here in our city hosted
its annual traditional Sunrise Service
uh yesterday morning yeah so this is
something that they've done every year
since one October the county along with
Metro pausing to remember uh featuring
live music and an honor guard there was
a minute of silence for the victims
there were remarks from governor sisalak
and Sheriff Lombardo
let's go
all right
yes we are following the shooting you
know items ranging from flowers to
everything everybody brought stuff at
the to the various memorials all over
town it really was incredible to see
that you know the bulk of those items
left at the crosses there um at the the
welcome to Las Vegas sign a lot of items
in fact about 22 000 pieces make up an
entire collection now that's stored at
the Clark County Museum and those
exhibits focuses on the stories behind
the certain items you know really
emphasizing Vegas strong as a
celebration of how the community came
together in the days following the
tragedy and following the shooting even
in the weeks following one October in
fact the collection is going to remain
on display at the Clark County Museum
until the end of January and
unfortunately Heather we're coming up on
the end of our broadcast here we
certainly we just started I know it went
by quicker than some of those runs I
think
thank you so much for tuning in Raiders
now is next on 8 news now thanks Heather
thank you everyone thank you now the
Smoke Clears all tears Spilled Out on
the event ground blood and cell phones
ringing intent to tear us down lose our
way and drown take away our peas very
hope deep underground but no not here
fool you don't have the tools to
deconstruct us a name demon killed many
but inspired more scars made but love
saved scars made but hope saved near
misses and lost kisses scattered in the
hot wind of Vegas as those who escaped
such evil lifted Talent shout it scream
it alive alive we are alive we will live
for those you left behind killed from
the tower but didn't kill hope nope
carry on and do no wrong you just can't
kill love we are still Vegas strong